Hey guys,
Our new merch designs are finally here.
So the only problem is we couldn't
choose on just one so we chose two.
This is my favorite.
Habakkuk 3.
And this is the design Nikita loves.
You like yours more than mine?
Well I like... I like both.
That's why we took both of them.
Yeah, that's true.
This is just a reminder
for you guys to always remember that you can
never find true peace and joy in this world
from temporary materialistic things.
It comes only from God Himself,
even when you go through trials and
tribulations you only find it in God.
And so He will make your feet like that of a deer.
To tread on high places.
There we go.
Love you guys,
Get the merch.
Get it for someone out there who
you need - who you know might need it.
Love you.
Bye.